Wildlife officials are baffled by the
first deadly mountain lion attack in
Washington State in nearly a century the
Cougar attacked two mountain bikers over
the weekend in a forest about 30 miles
east of Seattle near the town of North
Bend one man escaped his friend did not
DeMarco Morgan shows us how the Cougar
displayed unusual behavior before the
attack DeMarco good morning John good
morning to you as well the survivor
Isaac cedar bomb a 31 year old from New
York is in a hospital recovering from
his injuries and he is in satisfactory
condition authorities strike down the
mountain lion hours after the mauling
and shot and killed it state wildlife
agency this 100 pound cougar a three to
four yield mal injured one man and
killed another Saturday morning
the victims were mountain biking around
11:00 a.m. when they noticed the panther
chasing them
officials say the band stopped and did
what they were supposed to do try to
scare the predator away one of the
victims
swung their bike toward the animal has
it approached and that caused it to run
off into the woods but the reprieve was
short-lived the Puma returned moments
later and pounced on one of the bikers
Isaac cedar bomb he said he had his
whole entire head in the jaws of this of
this animal and was was being shaken
around horribly the big cat released him
and then attacked his friend Estabrooks
cedar bomb managed to get back on his
bike and rode about two miles until he
could get a cell phone signal to call
9-1-1 hours later rescuers cornered the
mountain lion and a tree and killed it
they first spotted it standing on brooks
body the Cougar had actually drugged the
victim back into the wood line and he
was found dead there a cougar was seen
in the same area three weeks earlier
it's unclear if the same animal attacked
the men this weekend the fact that it
stayed in close proximity of these folks
and attacked and stayed with them is
highly highly unusual wildlife officials
say the Cougar was emaciated even at 100
pounds and officials hope a necropsy can
help explain the animals odd behavior
they say there is no indication that the
victims taunted the big cat at the last
deadly attack in Washington was in 1924
when a 13 year old boy was killed
horrifying scene to picture that Thank
You DeMarco